foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
want to be found we're going to
disappoint him
these people they're just born plain
evil evil is cutting off a bird's Wing
just to see what happens
swatting mosquitoes why'd you say that
thing about mosquitoes I don't think
he's looking for Destruction I think
he's looking for Relief
she's staying I'd have to ask feed
transfer I'd be working for the bureau
you were rejected by The Bureau it was
your psycho Valley to do it aggressive
addictive anti-social
this is the profile of people we arrest
not hire I think you got talent I need
you to use it as fuel to bring me
something new now
this guy's on a spiral of Destruction I
expect you to slide down after him
races
somebody sold him back up we find them
we find our guy
why you might be getting a good read on
them
they brought me in because they thought
I'd understand you
you're making any progress I'm here
foreign